- On appelait Solitude, héroïne,
symbole de la lutte pour
liberté et la dignité. En 1802,
elle s'est jointe, enceinte,
Bonaparte a rétabli
en Guadeloupe, l'esclavage
qui avait été aboli après
Emprisonnée, elle a été exécutée
le lendemain de son
accouchement.
fois, avec une joie mêlée de
tristesse.
- Un extrait de la mulâtresse
Schwarz-Bart. Qui raconte
l'histoire de cette femme, née
d'une esclave, qui avait éténcnt
le long voyage depuis l'Afrique.
LAURENCE JOSEPH
Guadeloupéenne et comédiennepepe
parcours de toutes ces femmes
antillaises qui se battenten
fait, pour pouvoir exister tout
- La statue de Solitude érigée
dans ce jardin qui porte son
nom, a été la première à Parmmm.
JEAN-MARC AYRAULT, ancien PM
France, Fond. mémoire esclavage
- Aujourd'hui, nous faisons plus
Nous redonnons une image, nous
redoe e e e e silhouette,
un visage, une présence dans
notre vie aux 4 millions d'êtres
en esclavage dans les coloniesç.
- Ils sont plusieurs à souligner
l'importance de commémorer
le passé de nation négrière
en France, ici en métropole.
JACQUES MARTIAL, cons. déléguérs
- À un moment historique, nous
avons entendu des paroles
terribles pendant cette campagns
de haine, une parole que l'on
dit débrider face à l'horreur,
nous proposons la beautéutututu,
la beauté du combat contre les
injustices et pour les valeurs
qui nous animent.abababababababe
comprendre que la splendeur
passée de la France est liée
à l'esclavage soutientststststs.
JEAN HÉBRARD, profelelelelelelee
des Hautes Études sc. sociales
- Il suffit de se prdadadadadads
de l'Atlantique et
à quel point l'argent
de l'esclavage
oublier que sous Louis XIV,
en France,i i i i i i i venait
de Saint-Domingue était la
principa
- La ville de Nantes a étés s s.
Elle accueille ce mémorial
de l'abolition de l'esclavage.
Devoir de mémoire.eieieieieieiea
fait des efforts depuis la l
Taubira.
- Du nom de Christiane Taunenene
la justice a été à l
de l'adoption, le 10 mai 2001
de la loi française e e e e e ee
contre l'humanit
prévoyait également une plus
grande place
dans les programmes scolaires.
- Il est tilililililililile
d'enseigner les choses qui ne
sont pas
Enseigner la guerre d'Algérie,
enseigeieieieieieieieigner
l'esclavage ce n'est pas facile.
Do
de le faire vivre. De faire
anananananananants.
(chants)
- De
venus de partout en France ont
prmememememememememes et des
chants sur l'esclavage. Durant
présence du président français.
n n n n n n n n n pour Paris,
soutient le conseiller Jacques
les statuts des personnagestete.
- Édouard Glissant dit: l'oubli
mémoire, quand elle estagagagag.
Alors nous abolissons l'offense.
- L'tititititititititititititite
en 1848.
Ici Anyck Béraud,
Radio-Canada, Paris